[Music]
all right good afternoon everybody I'm
Carl and this is Evan and I hope you're
all here for the bigquery nested and
repeated fields dig deeper into data
sounds like a very long title for the
end of the long day so we'll do our best
to keep you guys energized then we have
a wonderful presentation prepared for
you just a couple of words about
ourselves my name is Carl osipov I'm a
staff program manager at Google cloud
and I help Google cloud customers and
partners succeed with our offering by
getting trained and certified in Evin
for 10 15 years and honestly using
bigquery is an absolute blast and
hopefully you'll see through some of the
demos here today and if you'd like to
learn more there's a lot of course er
courses that we do a lot of I'm on the
training and curriculum team that we
have as well so if you're not sick of
seeing my mug after today you're welcome
to watch eight hours of me teach
bigquery ml on Coursera alright awesome
and if you need to find out more about
us just feel free to reach out our
emails a really simple first name last
name at google.com so here's what the
session is about and really I want to
make this session about all of you so I
have some questions for you to start
with first of all if you are currently
analyzing data that's may be stored in
formats like jason javascript object
notation or xml could you please just
throw your hand up if you're analyzing
that type of data very good so maybe
about half of you and please keep
holding your hand so for those of you
who are holding your hand up how many of
you are analyzing that data using sequel
all right so we're down to maybe about
third and how many of you are analyzing
that data using sequel on bigquery
alright so now we're down to about 1/5
so I think for vast majority of you a
lot of the content here in this
presentation is going to be really
interesting so I'll explain this concept
of semi structured data that might be
new to many of you and then I'll help
you grow your sequel skills to help you
understand how to use features of sequel
2011 like arrays in structured type
to analyze semi-structured data so I
think most of you have seen bigquery by
now so I'm not gonna go too deep into
bigquery but I'll give a brief refresher
on this offering from Google Cloud and
then I'll show you how bigquery can help
you tap into this semi structured data
which is extremely important and we're
gonna have a lot of demos actually we'll
have a lot of live coding in this
session so don't expect this to be a
sales pitch this is going to be a lot of
a lot of fun examples you can take away
from this session and use on your own
projects and ultimately I know it's the
end of the day so we want to keep you
guys energized and hopefully come up
with some really good questions for us
so my question for you are there anybody
here in the audience who are analyzing
petabytes of data today could I just see
a show of hands oh I think we have
single digits and at a first glance
right petabyte of data that may sound
absurdly large in fact if you try to
download a petabyte of data over a
cellphone connection over 4g it will
take about 27 years to download all of
that and you know i'm dating myself a
little bit here but if you take those
old floppy disks is a five and a quarter
inch and try to stack them up on top of
one another to have a petabyte worth of
data capacity that's gonna be more than
12 Empire State building's you know it's
like over 100 libraries of Congress or
every tweet ever recorded more than 50
times so sounds like a lot but I'd like
you to think about a petabyte of data
slightly differently if you are in the
genomics field
well petabyte of data is just about two
micrograms of DNA if you try to sequence
that DNA or from Google's standpoint a
petabyte of data is how much Google gets
every day that's the amount of video
that Google gets uploaded into YouTube
on a daily basis and at this point you
can say look Carl you know I I don't do
genomics or my company is not Google so
it's it's not relevant to us but I
challenge you to think about petabytes
of data in the following way so think
about application servers or web servers
many companies many projects out there
have hundreds of these servers 200
servers is not a large number and if you
think about these application servers
just general generating log data just
logging maybe website visitors at 50
entries a second if you don't have a
petabyte of data now in three years with
these 200 application servers you have a
petabyte of data to analyze so the point
is even if vast majority of you are not
analyzing petabytes of data today you
will soon so what is that data and I'm
sure many of you know that the studies
have shown that 80 to 90% of that data
the data in the world is unstructured
data but I think if you hear the
bigquery session you probably have had
some experience with sequel was using
bigquery and you're comfortable with
structured data the data that's
organized into rows and columns data was
a relational schema and that's what you
want to analyze so it seems like a
challenge to think about all this
unstructured data all these images
natural language text videos and think
about how you can get value out of that
data well yes it's it's impossible
really to analyze unstructured data
using sequel but there's another very
important category of data that I want
to draw it you attention to and that's
semi structured data so if you want to
think about semi structured data
think about data in a format like JSON
or XML or even some key value databases
it's the data where you may have some
relational schema you can think about
parts of JSON objects in terms of the
schema that has strings or integers or
dates but at the same time it has some
data that doesn't really fit into a
relational traditional rows and columns
formats right think arrays or things
think about key value pairs or
dictionaries in in JSON so it seems like
there's a interesting category in the
middle between unstructured and
structured data types so it seems like
it might be interesting in some cases
other
practical examples of this kind of data
well I just wanted to mention this
recent announcement this was announced
back in May of this year Twitter the
social networking company actually
decided to migrate their infrastructure
over to Google cloud and think about the
contents of these tweets this is a
perfect example of semi structured data
just look at the that weed right here it
has natural language text but at the
same time this kind of data contains
embedded @ mentions this contains
hyperlinks and also has some structured
information with pointers to graphic it
has dates etc so this is a perfect
example of a kind of data that exists in
a semi structured format that many
companies may want to analyze and now
the Twitter is moving to Google Cloud
they'd be able to use Google cloud
capabilities like bigquery to analyze
this type of data and if you're still
skeptical I just wanted to give you a
few more concrete examples in preparing
for this talk actually went out and
thought about the developer activity
around semi structured data so the first
place that I went to was github the
source code repository and I went out
and tried to analyze the github commits
or file changes to various structured
and semi-structured data formats so this
is what I came up with I actually looked
at just the top five formats that you
see listed on the slide and if you're
wondering why top five is because other
formats like DD LS for sequel and others
actually were two resulted in too few
commits to make a make a significant bar
on this on this chart so this is one
interesting data point you can see over
a hundred million commits for Jason
relative to about 10 million for CSV
which is commonly used for structured
data and at this point you could say so
what all right so this is github commits
on one hand github is not really a data
repository and at the same time
developers often use JSON and XML as
their configuration files
something that we change all the time
and that's fair so I went out and looked
at other sites for developers the first
one I looked at was Stack Overflow and
you'll notice a pattern right so the
similar type of proportion exists if you
look at the semi structured data formats
like JSON and XML they receive
significantly more questions than CSV
and various variants of sequel so in
this case actually looked at the
questions for DDL formats as well so
that's just two data points but if you
go and look at other data sources like
the very well-known hacker news social
media website a similar pattern exists
in fact I went out and looked at Google
Trends Google's own data repository and
there's roughly the same proportion if
you compare the developer activity
around structured and semi-structured
data formats about 80 to 90 percent of
that activity happens around JSON XML
yamo the semi structured data formats as
opposed to structured data formats that
I want here together with CSV CSV tab
separated formats equal DDL and even
Park in a row so the point is there is
something there there's valuable set of
data that exists that developers are
working with but you need to ask
yourself are you getting insights out of
this data clearly it's important this
amount of data is drawing but what can
you do about it it seems like since it's
semi structured traditional sequel is
not really the right tool and this is
what I want to that's the point where I
want to change your opinion in this
session so how many of you are
first-timers to bigquery how many of you
who have never heard of dick query
before today oh my god this is the first
time I think I'm seeing single-digit
hands going up in this room so looks
like most of you know bigquery you know
it's a petabyte scale data warehouse
available from Google Cloud it can get
you results in seconds and some of the
reasons why is so fast
is it using this columnar based storage
format that behind the scenes is
supported by a file system that
automatically shards
the data and makes it available to you
as a bit query user at extremely high
throughput rates with very low latency
in what you'll look at in the moment is
this support for two types of data
structures in bigquery known as arrays
and struts and what I'll show you is
that both of these data types a part of
sequel 2011 standard so if you are
already a sequel guru but have not had a
chance to work with these two types of
data structures I think you'll find a
lot of interesting examples in this
session so one thing you need to know
about bigquery is that it consists of
two parts
there's bigquery storage that is the
data warehouse piece that maintains
warehouses your data and then there's
the bigquery and now Asus engine that
takes your sequel statements and uses
those sequel statements to analyze data
and what's great about bigquery is that
first of all it supports various types
of data formats and data input sources
for example you can get data into
bigquery from something like Google
Analytics firebase other services on
Google cloud like cloud datastore
and have that data reside inside of
bigquery storage and another thing that
is great about bigquery is that allows
you to use the bigquery analysis engine
to run sequel statements against data
that resides outside of bigquery storage
so for example you can use bigquery to
analyze data in something like cloud
storage buckets or in cloud BigTable and
bigquery is used by customers throughout
the world in fact at this point bigquery
supports exabytes of data for Google
cloud customers now let's let's wrap up
with the introductory part of the
presentation and shift into something
more technical so what I'd like to do
next is show you an example of analyzing
semi structured data with bigquery and
here's what I'll show you suppose I want
to build an analysis engine to find out
what the developers care about
developers are early adopters they sort
of force each
so what I'd like to be able to do is get
data from the web site known as hacker
news the social media website figure out
what a developer's talking about and
then use that information to help me
guide my decisions about which
technologies to learn in before this
session actually went out to hacker news
and I use their api's that happen to be
JSON based API JavaScript object
notation based API is to download some
sample data on my laptop and what I'll
do next is import that data into
bigquery here on stage now the way that
I'll import this data is that I'll take
this route shown on the screen with
letter A so imagine I have my JSON file
and I'll use the web UI that you see
here to import this data into the
bigquery storage now I can use the web
UI I can also use command line interface
from bigquery known as BQ tool I can
even use bigquery application
programming interfaces API is to do that
now that's the approach that I'll take
here during the demo if you're planning
to import data into bigquery in
production please I really ask you
please don't use this approach and
here's why if you're trying to approve
or data into bigquery using this direct
route there are many things that can go
wrong one of them you know if you're
using a browser browsers have
limitations on the sizes of files that
you can upload browsers can crash the
network connections can get interrupted
so if you're thinking about importing
data into bigquery storage in production
what I'd like you to do is follow this
route shown with letter B on the slide
so here's how it works
you're gonna take a tool known as GS
util it's a command-line utility you
will take your data and copy this data
into something called Google Cloud
storage and the great thing about this
gsutil tool is that'll be a
fault-tolerant
upload for your data meaning that gsutil
will actually resume data transfers if
there's a failure in the network
connections GSU till we actually take
check points to make sure that it
doesn't have to reapply the entire data
set it only reads the changes
to the network connection and one of the
coolest things about gsutil is that it
supports multi-threaded uploading which
means that you can control how much
bandwidth you may want to allocate to
the gsutil tool and then after you moved
your data via GS util into Google Cloud
storage then your data is inside of
Google Cloud and you can use the rest of
these tools that you see on the screen
to get your data into bigquery all right
so that's enough with an overview let's
switch over to the demo and I'll show
you how this works so as as you can see
right now I'm looking at the bigquery
user interface this loop should look
very familiar to most of you and notice
that here I have my bigquery project was
this long name but the we're gonna call
it a quick laps project so to import
data into this project I need to create
something called a data set a data set
is simply a container for the various
data tables that I have inside of
bigquery so I'm uploading hacker news
data let me just call it a Chan shirt
for hacker news I'm not going to specify
the location for this data I'll leave it
unspecified but if I wanted to I could
have set up data residency for this data
set in the US EU or Tokyo okay so now I
have this new data set let's actually go
ahead and create a new table in this
data set so I'll click create your table
and after I close the editor on the
right hand side you'll notice that on
the right side of my screen I have this
option to create a table from source
data and as I pointed out moments ago
just for this demo I'll upload a file
into this table from my local file
system and this file is going to be a
JSON document if you're wondering what
it looks like remember this is the data
that I received from the hacker news
website via the api's so I cleaned it up
a little bit and if you look at the data
here you can see that stip achill JSON
object so I have a date and then I have
these stories and now this starts
looking very different from most of
relational tables out there notice that
I have a single date and now within
these stories I have array of values
our titles of articles the number of
times they have been uploaded to score
the URL to these articles and so forth
so this is what the data looks like
let's go ahead and try to upload this
into bigquery so I'm gonna do a file
upload I'm gonna choose my JSON document
and let's call this destination table as
a Chan for hacker news and since this is
from December 2 2008 I'll use 2008 as
the suffix now I could have specified
the schema manually but here I'll trust
bigquery to figure out the schema of
this JSON document automatically let's
go ahead and click create table and when
I do this bigquery creates something
known as a job so in this case the job
happens to be to load the data inside of
the bigquery table I can see that the
job is complete so let's actually take a
look at this table let's preview the
contents of this table and you know this
should look familiar
notice that I have a single row of data
here's the URL to a story from hacker
news here's the score the number of
times that it has been uploaded its
title and then there's the date now if
you've used traditional relational
databases in the past this should stock
starts to look weird what happened to
this date I have all these values with
the title but now they're blanks for the
date where did the date go and notice
that I have many of these titles for a
single date so how do I analyze this
let's take a look at the schema maybe it
yes has some hints well this looks
familiar there's a date
it's nala both so data is a standard
sequel type they're strings integers all
that looks familiar but now there are
these stories and if you've never seen
this before
records repeated like what are these so
I've been doing sequel for a while but
now I'm totally confused so I don't know
what to do and at this point I'd like to
introduce my colleague Evan back on
stage he's gonna give us a to the tools
to better analyze this record repeated
strangeness in the schema
cool so whenever you have any problems
with nested and repeated field just call
me that's the that's the solution end of
demo no this assay blew me away so I've
been working with sequel for a 10-15
years and even before I was smart enough
as Carl mentioned to go into the schema
and look for that I was looking at the
data and the first thing that exactly as
Carl mentioned you have one row and for
me being a structured data guy in the
background as a data analyst scrolling
over and seeing the date here and what I
thought was null records that kind of
lost my mind I'm like ah this is really
really weird even still you have what
you thought was one field but it has a
dot in it you've got stories dot title
you've got stories dot score so it
almost looks like it's like two
different tables in one you've got dates
and you've got articles and you know the
details all in one place so that's we're
gonna get into the magic as we work
through some of these sequel queries
that you're gonna see but the real
exciting part about it for me personally
even if your data isn't in this format
already it could be that's the really
really fun part is because in
traditional relational database sense
normally you might have multiple
different tables it's stored in multiple
different places in a technical term
that we called normalization and that's
great for relational databases but
picori doesn't operate that way and you
get a huge huge potential performance
boost by bringing your data together
potentially and what I like to call a a
pre joint or a nested nested way so
let's run through a bunch of queries and
I got some cool questions for you guys
too
unfortunately wish I'd like some swag or
something like that that's right in the
crowd but you'll just have to make do so
first and foremost if you're familiar
with sequel you're probably seeing a lot
of like select star and looking at some
of these might be just a little bit
baffling but stick with it
so the first thing we want to do is you
can actually create array types and so
nice booming voice you can create array
types directly in the Indus equal so
what I'm gonna do I'm still in the
bigquery web UI if you didn't know what
already if you actually highlight a
portion of the query I'm hitting command
e on the on the Mac we can actually
execute just a partial statement of the
sequel so I've got a long sequel
statement then I'll I'm gonna walk
through and execute each portion as you
see so I've got an array that I want to
create as you saw in the image a little
bit earlier I have four different fruits
that I wanna fill into my little array
basket so I'm saying this is gonna be an
array an array again it's just going to
be a collection of those items that
share a single a singular data type so
that's the critical part is that I'm
saying hey everything that's gonna be in
this collection isn't gonna be a string
so arrays have to share this single data
type that's gonna come back in one of
the key points because we talked about
later so as you saw on the results again
if I haven't really worked a lot with
with arrays and bigquery this might look
super strange and the really cool part
is if you hover over the type you see
hey not only is it a string in there but
it's repeated so that's how you get your
repeated data in there or do you have
for what seemingly looks like four rows
with one row here so first time I saw
that I was like okay let's see let's see
how far we can take this alright well do
I need to necessarily specify the string
these all in brackets there earlier no I
don't the query smart enough to
recognize that if you're passing in
things that look like they're in string
a notation sure all interpreted as a
string for you as you see here still
it's still gonna be a string all right
well what are some cool things that you
can do once you have your your data
inside of arrays or you're accessing a
data set that already has arrays and by
the way the reason why we're creating
these arrays normally if you had a field
you could just have the field name in
here but we just wanted to show you the
special sauce with what's behind it so
we have we're setting up our data set
and our data set is just literally gonna
be the array that you see here it says
give me this array or an array of fruit
and with that fruit array I'm gonna
select something I'm gonna go into the
fruit or fruit already I'm gonna pull
back the element in the second position
anyone want to take a guess is it gonna
be a raspberry a blackberry strawberry
or cherry at position number two okay
everyone and we get this huge conference
- I'm like very yeah
a strawberry is exactly correct so if
you work with arrays before I can even
get easily tripped up with like all
right well is it zero based or is it is
it one based as well so you see zero for
raspberry blackberry and then
blackberries number one strawberries
number two that's because you're using
offset all right if my alias is don't
give it away people in the audience are
just like I'm just reading this query
you see that you can have it as ordinal
which is the same thing as offset except
you have ordinal starting with 1 so 1 2
is now Blackberry instead so accessing
array elements this is like a
fundamental part of like okay you got
your data into an array
how do you actually get it out of it all
right what happens if you ask if you did
this then I got four or four records in
there well it's gonna look for the 999th
in there I didn't find it it's out of
bounds overflow I'm gonna do big queries
you're not charged for queries that
result in an error and this is this is a
super friendly I mean I go to war with
the validator on a daily basis but
honestly it's your best friend because
you can actually talk about open you can
see whether or not your query is gonna
execute with an error without so if you
get that green the green checkmark
you're in good shape what other things
can you do with raise you could do be
like cool array aggregation so if you
want to see how many elements are in the
array it's just a simple function array
length
I knew the mine you're my old begin to
think of like huh but what I want to
know like why I was in right brain
lights matters before Carla's example I
showed earlier how many articles were
published in a day just the length of
the array do mathematical operations
what about if I wanted to do a little
bit more complex topics here's a big one
exactly as Carl mentioned before this
isn't the first point where I hit my
first stumbling block and trying to
really understand this I have a field
that's in array I'm just hard coding
this array right here apple pear and
plum and then I have a field that's not
an array so this is where it gets really
interesting so we've got repeated string
and then we've got all of these items in
this array associated with this customer
but keep in mind this is the the massive
kind of learning point is that this is
all in a singular row still so this is
what's called an unflattering array
let's see what happens when we flatten
it so in order to perform general sequel
operations on this we need to get things
and you know into a 1 element per row
context and this is where the syntax
starts to get the better of some people
but it's not too bad
so let's see what we got now we're
bringing back the items the customer
names and this is the magical command is
unnecessary thing out so why you had one
row with 3 items before we've
essentially squished it with one one row
for each of the items in the array and
you're doing what's called a correlated
cross join which basically says remember
when I had an apple pear and peach in
just one Jacob just associate with that
with each of the
in there it's not like a is kind of like
a traditional cross joint but it's not
cross running across all of your all the
different possible Rea values it's just
cross running against just that one that
it's associated with this is actually
optional syntax so if you ever see this
in code that's fine also you can just
have a comma there and that works
because that's treated as a cross join
so unnecessary
and the reason why here I like to think
of unnecessary well unnecessary breaks
apart my array into one element on each
each separate row but even more
philosophically you can think of this
separate array that you're bringing in
almost is like a separate table and
that's why you're unnecessarily in
sequel you say select a lot of stuff
from a different table join it on
another table that's that kind of the
simple walkthrough for any data analyst
you're replacing that by saying I have
all my data in this one table but at
different hierarchies how do I get it on
the same hierarchy well instead of doing
the joins between tables you're now done
nesting within that singular table some
other cool things you can do if you
imagine you can find out what the order
of the element in the array was super
useful and that's just simply by the
reserve keyboard offset and your weights
have the index of the each different
items in there so you could find do
things like minimums maximum latest item
that's in there as well so this is just
the tip of the iceberg Karl and I have a
limited time to present all of the the
cool things you can do with nested
repeated fields but there's two key
takeaways it's getting your data into
arrays is is rather simple and working
with the syntax and once it's in arrays
you're largely gonna be working with
unnecessary is all that means is it's
taking elements in or in no array that's
in a singular row like five items in one
row and having five items being five
separate rows so we can do array
creation this is saying I have a data
set that just has strings we're going
the other way now so I have one two in
the third row for banana now we're going
the reverse we're packing all those into
an array and you can't do a raise of
arrays I'm gonna show you something just
in a minute that has a really cool
container aspect of it same queries
before but if you wanted to do a nice
order let's see if we can't get
apple banana pear and you can there you
go honestly it's much like you would
treat another different table in there
as well same order by works all right a
little bit more complex what happens if
I wanted to do just a filter I want to
filter only to include items that I want
from one of those particular rows and
here's where gets really interesting so
if you had something like this which is
working well we're gonna repeat in the
next query to get at say I want to
return just the customers that have
apples in their fruit basket I first
need to access that array remember
accessing the arrays involves flattening
them squashing them into different one
row for each different element in the
array so we need to first do that so at
the first you'll see all right well this
is our global list
let's unless the and then we can just
operate over just look normal because if
Row one is Apple Row two is banana Row
three is pear we can just filter that
just like a normal sequel query and then
we can combine it back into an array
format at the outset so it's going into
the array it's squishing it so we can
operate over it and then it's putting it
all back together in an array and you
can see in the query results here this
returns all of the the customers in this
particular case the customers back up
baskets that had Apple in it notice that
the third row or the third array returns
a null or an empty set so keep that in
mind when you're working with arrays is
that if the condition doesn't match in
like Choa Choa your traditional joins
you might not get a record return but
you'll get an empty set and also okay so
that is arrays that's half of what I
call the magic so if you understand
arrays and unnecessary you know a decent
couple of weeks to really wrap my head
around the UH nesting syntax but
philosophically think about it as a
separate table now Karl also mentioned a
really really cool other native sequel
2011 syntax a data type that's supported
by bigquery and that's the structure
structure
think of it like a container this is
where it gets really interesting you
have one field we're specifying
that it can unlock an array you can
contain different data types within one
field so we're gonna say it's an integer
for the first field it's a string for
the second field and we're saying 35 for
this field we're not giving it a name
yet and we're saying a string of Jacob
for the second one
any thoughts what's missing here or
looks fun what's funny about this
there's two things that are missing any
thoughts yeah the names so we have her
missing not only the name of the field
let's execute this if I just ran that
piece okay so I'm specifying this as 35
is going to be the age Jacob's gonna be
the name but also since this is a
collection right it's a collection of
these fields you need to give the
overall container a name and this is the
foundation of the nested and repeated
fields where now I'm storing something
where I have multiple fields associated
with a single piece of information in
this particular case customers where I'm
storing multiple data points why is this
useful if you're thinking in the back
your head that looks just like a table
that I'm bringing in customers that age
customers that name imagine having other
Struck's in here storing things like
items that are in their shopping carts
or transaction history instead of having
a massive schema with 15 different
things like you do in the transactional
world you bring that all together into
one massive reporting table through the
use of structs now here's where it gets
really interesting of course you were
already familiar with arrays you can
have arrays inside of these containers
as well so now we're slowly building
together our grocery grocery example
here we now have what you saw before the
age and then the name and then we're
also hard coding and array data type in
there so you saw this before repeated
string but now it's part of a collection
of customers in there as well now you
can go the opposite direction as well
you can actually have an array of struct
data types so the combination of using
arrays and structs is super powerful the
two key points that I'll leave you with
are one if you see a schema that looks
that looks like this
as Carl I showed before actually I'll
just jump into hacker news
this is the Google Analytics schema so
Google is the dog foods its own schemas
in the sense of if we're telling you
guys this is a great way to store highly
performant data you know you're gonna
see that out on the wild so if you have
Google Analytics data exactly as Carl
was showing you before if you're looking
through your schema and you say ok
energy energy energy energy whoa what is
this record here that is a struct it's a
collection and you see it's a totals
collection so much like where you might
have had a separate table for session
details about the visitor and then
session details about the the totals for
the visitor this is all now within the
same table and the reason easiest way
you can find that is look for data types
that have records and I'll show you just
as a fun example you can have pretty
wide schemas now so there's I don't you
can see that there's 32 different struck
that are available within even just like
google analytics schema and where it
gets really interesting if you take this
the you know even further you can have
structs inside of structs so for google
analytics how it stores the data is
global information about the hits data
at that one level what about particular
pages ok sure hits that page that page
passed you can go and almost you know
like Inception a couple layers deep
there as well so again this is just kind
of stretch scratching the surface with
what we can do it's a with the time
allotted but it's a super fun concept
even if you have your existing data
consider working with getting it into
arrays instructs to see if there's a
performance impact if you're doing a lot
of joins between your transactional data
to get it into one place
perhaps store it on the reporting data
table side into an S and repeated format
and see instead of doing those
potentially expensive sequel of joins on
the on your queries to see if you can't
get more performance benefit from doing
nested and repeated also as a side plug
we're doing a full day bootcamp 2 on
Friday 8 hours I said you wanted to get
more experience working with bigquery or
working with data pipelines data flows
and we have a new lab on the bigquery
machine learning which was at the
keynote a little bit earlier today
you're welcome to show this out as well
but we are going to close this session
Carl is gonna come on back up and show
you actually how we take our hacker news
data that we ingested a little bit
earlier and work with that in this
format thanks Evan
Evan I really appreciate it because now
I feel even though I'm just a program
manager that I can do really cool stuff
with with bigquery was nested and
repeated fields so let me just make sure
that I cover some of the key takeaways
from what Evan said and Evan can keep me
honest here so the first thing to
remember about arrays and bigquery there
these lists that can have zero or many
values right they're ordered lists of
items but all the values in the array
must have the same data type you can
have arrays of integers strings and so
on right very important and the other
point that you need to remember here
when you're talking about the arrays
these are sequel 2011 arrays standard
arrays all right so that was a raise
let's move forward and talk about the
struts so what are structs so structs
can have many different data types you
can have structs with integers struts
with strings you can even have structs
with a raise right remember you cannot
have a raise inside of a raise but you
can have a raise inside of struts and if
you're wondering about the connection
here to the sequel 2011 standards these
struts are sequel 2011 structured types
all right so I hope this makes sense to
happen so far I think it makes sense to
me and this is where I had my what I
call an inception style moment when I
understood these nested and repeated
fields in bigquery they're just arrays
containing structs that may have arrays
inside of them with other structs with
other struts and arrays and so forth so
as it's cold sometimes it's Turtles all
the way down okay so that was the key
takeaway we have these structs in a
raise now let's think about what this
means in context of this hacker news
dataset remember I started this
presentation talking about JSON data
that looks kind of like this so now
let's think about it from the standpoint
of what was imported into bigquery and
how bigquery actually recognized as data
and created the schema
so here's my hacker news table and now I
know from Evan that repeat it simply
means an array and record is just
destruct so here I have an array of
struts that maintains these stories and
at this point I feel confident from
Evans training on these struts and
arrays so I'm gonna attempt something
extremely risky I'm actually gonna do
some live coding right here on stage
live demo live coding here on stage to
try to analyze this data and try to get
some awesome results because here's what
I'd like to be able to do remember was
this hacker news data I'd like to be
able to go to a particular day from
hacker news and let's say I want to pick
the top 5 most highly uploaded articles
and if you're wondering why top 5 or top
2 as shown on the screen basically here
you're seeing only two top two articles
for each day because that's how many I
could fit in the slide
alright so that's that's what I want to
get I want to have rows with date and
then for each day two stories so let's
go back to my bigquery UI I'm going to
query this stable but the first thing
that I'll do and actually I recommend
that all of you do the same is switch
over to something known as standard
sequel dialog so I'll disable legacy
sequel and I will use standard sequel
for my analysis so now let me go ahead
and query the stable and here's a
prepared
sequel query that I'm gonna use so few
things to notice here what's going on in
this query this first part of the from
statement is my project ID the HN is my
data set where I have the table HN 2008
with my hacker news stories data so just
to make sure that this works let me go
ahead and just pull in the dates from
that from the data set execute the query
and see what comes up and just as I
expected
I simply have a list of these dates so
these happen to be all the dates from
December of 2008 so pretty
straightforward
now what I want to be able to do is that
for each day each date from my data set
I want to have two taps scoring articles
so this means I'll have multiple records
for each day and what does this mean
this means I need to create an array so
let's go ahead and say I want to create
an array and to do that I'll type in
array and where is the data for this
array gonna come from that's the
important question well if I check much
my schema what I want to have inside of
this array are the story scores and the
story titles okay
so the first thing that I need to do
since I know it's an array of structs
right repeated means array record means
a struct let's uh nest a nest that array
so let's uh nest or YZ and that's where
the data is gonna come from so I'm gonna
use the keyword from from unnecessaries
and what do I select from there well
since it's a struct inside of those
stories let's do a select s struct and
what I'd like to get are the story
scores so let's do a score and the title
ok and what I'd like to do is to give a
name to this array so let's just call it
stories so the entire array of my top
scoring articles is going to be called
stories and this looks pretty good but
remember on my slide I could only feel
tube top two so let's add limit two so I
can only look at the top two articles
for each day and let's go ahead and do
an order by because I want to know all
the top scoring articles for each day so
I'll do it order by score in the
descending order so I'll open up my
editor I'll select us to run it do a
quick sanity check if anybody thinks
this is broken
Evon keep me honest here so let's let's
let it run all right so it's running and
bam there it is so that's exactly what I
expected from my slide I have each day
in December of 2008 for each day I have
two top scoring articles and now I can
start doing cool stuff with this I can
put this data into machine learning
api's from google cloud try to you know
sentiment I can use this data to extract
out most common topics whatever the
people hacker news were discussing that
day and this the most important thing is
that it gets me started with analyzing
this kind of semi structured data so
let's let's recap what I want you guys
to think about is what we said in the
beginning about semi structured data
you're never going to have as much data
in the semi structure the structure camp
as our colleagues who are working with
images videos sound and so on but now
think about all the semi structured data
you have within your company or maybe on
your project you're probably paying for
that data you're storing it somewhere
but are you getting insights out of that
data are you getting value from that
data if not I want you to think about
using bigquery to analyze that data and
use standard sequel 2011 struts and
arrays to help you with that analysis
and hopefully you know you guys now
excited to broaden your skill set with
sequel and actually start doing this so
if you are interested I want to
reiterate what Evan said a little bit
earlier we have a one day bootcamp that
focuses on taking marketing data
analytical analytics data that uses
struts and repeated fields and
throughout this marketing analytics day
bootcamp that we have on Friday starting
at 9:00 a.m. you'll spend the day
basically analyzing data and getting
some value out of this marketing
analytics data for for your own project
so that's going to be at 9 a.m. in
Moscone South and if you haven't seen
this link yet and if you're interested
in learning more about doing this kind
of analysis with bigquery I encourage
you to sign up for this Coursera
promotion if you go to coursera.org
slash next 18 you can actually get one
month free subscription to use various
on-demand Coursera classes from Google
cloud that include topics like how
Google does machine learning they
include topics and using bigquery for
analysis and also many other topics like
cloud architecture and then I'll just
leave these links here you can go to
Google search and search for things like
bigquery quickly
absorb it query public datasets if you'd
like to learn more
[Music]